what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson thanks for stopping by
the channel and most of you may know and
if you don't this is going to be an
excellent surprise for you John Bernthal
is returning as The Punisher in
Daredevil born again and before you
start wondering if this is just a rumor
or some sort of supposed leak nope this
is 100 confirmed by John Bernthal
himself and Daredevil born again is well
underway with filming they've been
filming for a couple of months now we've
seen plenty of behind the scenes photos
but today we have a video of John
bernthal's The Punisher along with
another Punisher and this could mean
something big or it could mean nothing
at all however we are in the Multiverse
Saga right now and anything is possible
so let's watch the clip and let's talk
about how a lot of things are about to
connect with Daredevil Spider-Man
Kingpin the midnight Suns and how
Marvel's going to be connecting things
leading up to the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars and if you love Marvel be
sure to subscribe to the channel we
update every day we also have a patreon
account now you can check out the link
down below a Discord and a website
running now as well let's check out the
video
I'm I didn't know you got to get them in
the head get them down
that was a 10. that was a 10.
oh it's kind of light
[Music]
feels great
try to do this as fast as you humanly
possibly can okay don't worry about
safety so this video is extremely cool
John berthal training for his upcoming
role as The Punisher once again however
you may notice something pretty iconic
about this video you may have noticed
there's another actor in this video and
that is Thomas Jane the man who played
the iconic Punisher in the 2004 movie so
as you can imagine this video has
sparked a lot of questions in the fandom
the biggest one being is Thomas Jane
returning as The Punisher as well
because as the video shows he is also
seemingly training he's doing Punisher
training now he could just kind of be
there because John Bernthal asked him to
be there after all he played The
Punisher in the past he has training
experience as playing The Punisher and
perhaps Jon Bernthal just asked him
there for his input John Bernthal has
been known to consistently practice at
the shooting range so perhaps he is
simply going back to the range to get
ready to play The Punisher and he has
Thomas Jane there for input but of
course we're all thinking this is the
Multiverse Saga there are variants now
and technically the two of them are
variants of each other we've already
seen old X-Men return from the fox
Universe from the old Fox X-Men movies
that are completely separated from the
MCU however now with Professor X
returning in Multiverse of Madness it is
confirmed that basically any Marvel
movie or show that has ever been done if
Marvel now owns the rights to them they
can put them anywhere in a movie or in a
Disney plus series and I do think Thomas
Jane's Punisher could return but I don't
think it's gonna be in Daredevil born
again now this video was posted on the
Instagram page of the official account
for Taran tactical and what's funny is
the caption for the video is literally
enter The Punisher Multiverse now we
know that Jon Bernthal is returning for
a major role in Daredevil's born again
he is not simply returning for just one
cameo in one episode he is fully coming
back Vincent D'Onofrio has already
confirmed this he says that Jon
bernthal's Punisher plays a major
character throughout the entire series
now we are in the Multiverse Saga but I
don't think Daredevil is really going to
involve the Multiverse too much unless
he's been around in the MCU for a lot
longer than we think and being in New
York he could have a connection to
doctor strange after all Daredevil did
interact with Spider-Man or I should say
Matt Murdock interacted with Peter
Parker but they're only one person away
Matt Murdoch is one person away Peter
Parker from Doctor Strange so perhaps
there is some sort of a connection there
however I'm not expecting too much
multiple stuff to happen and Daredevil
Born Again Daredevil born again is going
to set up a lot moving forward and go
into the new Spider-Man films and New
Avengers films as well however I don't
think the Multiverse is going to be such
a huge part until we get to the King
Dynasty and Thomas Jane I think is not
going to show up until then as well and
probably after that actually I do
believe Thomas Jane could be preparing
for his return as a variant of the
Punisher because based off of what we've
heard so far between the Kang Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars there are still
going to be movies and shows that are
coming out and based off of the rumors
this isn't confirmed but based off of
the rumors that we've heard the movies
and shows that are going to happen in
between could possibly take place
completely and entirely in other
universes so King Dynasty Will
essentially end with Kang sort of
winning and dominating the Multiverse so
these other projects will show what is
happening in these other universes with
these other teams like the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four the Illuminati and out of
all of these other universes that we are
going to see we would like to assume
that Thomas Jane is going to return and
play a variant of the Punisher in one of
those universes so we'd like to think
that John Bernthal gave Thomas jaina
Collins said hey I'm returning as The
Punisher you're eventually gonna return
as well you want to hit the shooting
range and start preparing that's what we
hope but perhaps he could just be there
to give him some input and invite advice
and just to kind of have a good time
with him let us know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below now as I
mentioned in previous videos it does
look like Marvel Studios and the MCU is
setting up for the debut of the midnight
Suns they might not call them the
midnight Suns but that is what they
seemingly are preparing for we've done
previous videos on it that will link in
the description and in the Ping comment
but basically we have characters like
Moon Knight blade who is about to enter
the MCU soon Deadpool who is about to
enter the MCU soon as well Elsa
Bloodstone man thing Doctor Strange who
put the midnight Sons together and soon
The Punisher all of these characters who
are a part of the midnight suns in the
comics at one time or another are now
all a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and we've already seen the
supernatural side of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with these characters
that have already been in the MCU or are
coming Kevin feige has confirmed we are
going to see different sets of teams in
the MCU so we're assuming this
Supernatural team is naturally going to
be called The Midnight Suns or severely
hinted at perhaps they could be the dark
Avengers even though that's not not what
the dark Avengers are in the comics
that's what they could call them either
way the characters that form this team
in the comics are already in the MCU or
are coming to the MCU soon so what
exactly is this all building up to well
I do think it's building up to something
big but separate from the Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars and this is actually why
I'm really excited for the future of the
MCU yes we are going to have these huge
crossover events like Secret Wars but at
the same time we're going to have other
huge events kind of sub huge events
happen in the different parts of the MCU
so the cosmic side gets a big event
every now and then the Avengers team of
course the street level Avengers get
their big event in The Avengers films
the normal ones not the huge team up
films I'm talking about the first
Avengers film the second Avengers film
Age of Ultron not Infinity war and end
game and of course Secret Wars that's
why we don't believe King Dynasty is
going to be that big of a crossover we
think that's being saved for Secret Wars
and lately it looks like the villain of
the supernatural side has probably been
revealed with Aubry Plaza's character
coming in Agatha coven of chaos now
we're not 100 sure who this is yet but
we are kind of thinking it's Mephisto
kind of the same thing about the
midnight Sun's title they might not call
her Mephisto she could be referred to as
the devil or a demon but we're thinking
that that's who she's gonna be so this
could all be leading up to a big battle
against her character and that's only
one side of the MCU that I think John
berthal's The Punisher could be a part
of I also think he could be a part of
the street level Avengers as well we
know Matt Murdock AKA Daredevil is going
to be a part of that team we also know
that Spider-Man and She-Hulk and Falcon
possibly Bucky slash the Winter Soldier
are going to be a part of that team too
and it would really make sense since the
Punisher is going to be so heavily
involved in the Daredevil show and it's
been said that Daredevil and Spider-Man
are going to eventually meet up in the
MCU it would make sense that the
Punisher would kind of go along for that
ride as well right now Kingpin is being
set up to be a big bad of the street
level Avengers team Hawkeye and Kate
Bishop have already come kind of contact
with him already so he is on an Avengers
radar Hawkeyes and from what we've heard
Fisk AKA Kingpin is going to be running
for mayor of New York so his crime
organization is about to get pretty big
so big that it's probably going to
require a pretty big Avengers team to
take down now as far as timeline goes I
unfortunately think that a lot of this
is going to happen after Avengers Secret
Wars but it does give us something to
look forward to after a really really
big event Marvel has already showed us
phase five and some of phase six and it
doesn't really seem like these other big
team up subunit movies can go inside of
phase six anywhere because building up
to King Dynasty we probably are going to
get a little bit of Multiverse stuff
especially I'm assuming with the
Fantastic Four but who knows perhaps
they could come before perhaps the teams
could be formed before King Dynasty and
then going into Secret Wars we have a
bunch of different teams coming together
that would be epic but as of right now
based off of what we know this is all
probably happening after secret War but
just think about the next big crossover
event after Secret Wars after the next
Saga at the end of it we'll have so many
new teams to actually come together and
cross over including the X-Men the
Fantastic Four and then we'll have the
midnight Suns the street level Avengers
The Cosmic Avengers so if you were
worried about Marvel Studios kind of
slowing down eventually and possibly
running out of content or characters
that's not gonna happen anytime soon and
yes the MCU lately has been shaky for
some people but Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 was great and I believe the future
of the MCU can be great as well if it's
executed properly which I do have faith
in Kevin feige so let us know all of
your thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos also leave a
comment down below to enter our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items winner gets to pick and we pick a
winner at the end of each month don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf
beep